well as more people become vaccinated
it's opening the doors for international
travel just in time for a summer
vacation
the european union is planning to reopen
its borders to those who have received
their shots
reporter kate houston spoke to some
local travel agents about
what to keep in mind before you book
your next vacation
i feel very excited don lykins is
gearing up for a trip to zurich with her
husband this september
there's a lot of people now that are
really having to work
and so that travel is even more
important to get a break
after missing out on multiple trips last
year she's looking forward to spending
time with her family
i think all of us would like to get out
and
you know travel just about anywhere are
you looking for
hotel and airfare at sunrise travel and
tours phones are ringing off the hook
i'm so excited that people are getting
vaccinated
and then i think the travel will start
epic cruz is seeing an
increase in demand for european
vacations as well as trips to hawaii and
the caribbean
we are calling to all the embassies
consulate
to get the right information on tuesday
the tsa screened 1.4 million people
compared to 190 000 last year at this
time
abby lagman with blissful travel company
says that demand will only grow from
here
summer is coming up and so a lot of
people are trying to find these last
minute deals
lagman says italy greece and iceland are
bringing in the crowds
jump on it now it's starting to fill up
i'm seeing things filled up even
up to 2022. because of changing
guidelines lagman and cruz recommend
investing in travel insurance
and being flexible things are happening
so quickly with things opening up
and just as quickly as they're opening
up just remember they can just as
quickly
shut down kate houston 8 news now
the european union will give an exact
date for when the borders reopen once
the countries approved those guidelines